alright my name's mark weed I'm with
think box software and I'm going to talk
a little bit about point cloud
processing we've got an application
we're building called sequoia which
we've been developing some algorithms
and data structures a file format for
and so I'm here to basically give a
little bit of a peek under the hood as
to what what it takes to write a
scalable point cloud kind of system so
to start I'm going to give a little bit
of a run-through of what our point
clouds and what how do they work what do
you do with them somewhat so point cloud
is basically just in a coordinate system
of some kind a whole bunch of points you
typically have data attached to it so
you can think of it like if you have a
table it's just like XYZ coordinates
followed by other data and was important
in a point cloud is the spatial
structure of it like what it represents
something in space so typically we're
dealing with 3d space and you see it in
medical imaging where you can represent
volumes as like point clouds like the
number of points can represent density
or something along those lines the most
common case is surfaces so you do light
our scanning or photogrammetric
reconstructions of surfaces that's lots
of samples of the surfaces of some model
but you can also do curves like hair or
points like if you want to represent the
stars in a system you might be
simulating or something these are all
point clouds and a closely related thing
is particle systems which
is a little bit more what I've
personally dealt with and that's you
take a point cloud and you attach some
kind of programmable dynamic system to
it basically your points might have
velocities that depend on neighboring
points or some some system that's like
makes them swirl around so it's very
common in visual effects and in games
these are a couple of screenshots from
products that we've crumb movies that
use some products that we created for
dealing with large volumes of particles
so that's one of the things where is our
core strengths is point particle systems
but we've got a bunch of software
highlight Krakatoa renders large volumes
of particles frost meshes produces
watertight meshes process is very fast
and stoke is a highly programmable
system that's also artist friendly and
lets you remix particle systems so you
can kind of replay the same dynamics but
on a different like say more points or
you can then mix it with 3d fields and
apply like Alerian constraints to like
manipulate your velocities make them
flow divergence free things like that
kind of like like a toolkit of some
fluid simulation primitives that kind of
let you flexibly tweak things so our
tools are very good at these particle
systems and people started using them on
their point clouds in industries outside
of what we were normally selling to so
that's where we got the idea to create
sequoia and let's i'm going to like show
some of the details of like the
foundational building blocks of such a
point cloud system
so there's also quite a bit of open
source code that deals with point clouds
so this screenshot from point cloud
library site kind of gives a nice
overview of what kind of things you
might want to do with point clouds so
you might do lidar scan and get a whole
bunch of points then you know I want to
do some kind of filtering get rid of
noise whatever segment into different
classes turn it into surfaces this is
very typical workflow lives is a very
common file format you run into when
dealing with point clouds and there's a
library that helps you manipulate them
and it has python bindings so you can do
some basic things just from Python in
this way it is a little bit tricky to
install and it doesn't say integrate
title as far as I could see with numpy
and some of that so there is perhaps
some things to be desired for for it but
it's yeah it's a format you can download
a lot of open data that's in this in
this format there's a library called
poetry which is being developed it's a
JavaScript library but it actually gives
you like embeddable web point cloud
viewers so this is an example is
basically fully interactive in your
browser you can like fiddle around
there's some parameters to tweak things
and whatever but yeah that's that's kind
of some of the tools that are out there
the free libraries available point cloud
library and particularly in particular
has some things that are very similar to
what I'll be talking about they
of an octree can deal with large data
sets I'm going to talk about it in a
particular way which i think is really
good but first some background on
spatial data structures if you want to
do something sophisticated with a point
cloud you kind of need to put it in a
spatial data structure first and what
that's typically going to let you do is
ask for given a point in space what are
the nearest and particles or given a
ball of some radius what are all the
points within that ball so some common
ones are the octree now in an octree you
start with the cube you divide the cube
into eight sub q buen you maybe pick
some some of those and you keep
subdividing very simple it's a tree
pretty easy to work with another one is
a KD tree so in a KD tree you start with
a box it doesn't need to be a cue the
size don't need to be the same you pick
an axis you split it into two half
spaces and then you recursively split
those you can pick an access for those
so in this example it's alternating
between like x y&z in the kinds of KD
trees I've developed is actually
advantageous to pick the axis /
splitting point based on what the data
actually looks like another one is
bounding volume hierarchy so in that you
basically find nearby or adjacent
objects you group them together and then
you basically make a some kind of tree
maybe a binary tree or multi white tree
so each of these have different
characteristics so if I go back like
octree is very simple it's not it's
adapted to the day
can be adaptive to the data in terms of
like okay there's more points here let's
split more but which boxes which cubes
you're going to get is predetermined
from your root cube Katie tree kind of
improves on that a little bit in the
sense that now you can choose your
splitting pain planes based on where the
data is and that can get you faster
lookups you don't have to search as far
down the tree you can skip over things
quicker but it also means if you're like
want to modify your points in some way
well now rebuilding the tree is a bigger
more complicated option in operation and
maybe you have to look at your points
more when building the KD tree and the
bounding volume hierarchy is actually
really good if you have like
well-defined things that are moving like
animating so in like a video game
setting this is the kind of thing you
might want for a collision detection of
animated models that are going around
and hitting hitting each other possibly
but it's also very freeform and like
maintaining spatial structure isn't
necessarily like on just fully free form
data is not quite as well defined as the
other ones so we're using an octree for
sequoia and it's based on something
called floating-point Morton order and
this works out really well for
scalability for out of core behavior and
so we'll see a little bit why something
very related is the fast multipole
method and so lorena barber gave the
keynote this morning project she was
involved in called x 0 FF fmm is
exploring or it's a library that lets
you compute the fast multipole method on
like multi-threaded code or on the GPU
and it's kind of pushing the idea of
fast multipole method is the kind of
algorithm you need if you're going to
EXO scales you're like because it's a
big o of n algorithm for computing the
n-body problem solution and their code
if you go peek inside and look at the
comments and see what they're doing
they're using an octree and they're
using Morton order for for dealing with
the spatial structure of the points in
this case may be it's like stars or
something if the thing you're you're
solving for is actually like gravity or
something so warden order also called
zet order because of how if you pick
your access a certain way it looks like
a Zed it's basically a way to order
integer coordinates that has some really
nice spatial behaviors and in particular
you ten it tends to make points that are
close together in space and 2d space in
this case be close together in your 1d
linearized version of your points so
what I'll kind of walk you through a few
steps to understand like what what it
does how it's built up I'll do that by
starting with more in order in one
dimension and it's not it's not really
more in order because it's like kind of
trivial but it's based on the binary
representation of the numbers so I've
broken out five and seven and so 5 is 0
1 0 1 you can see it going down down
this diagram and 7 is 0 1 1 1 going down
the diagram and basically you look from
the most significant bit down to the
least significant bit and at each point
you're splitting your entire space of
numbers in two so we look at the
most significant bit it's the same so
both numbers are in the left half of
your number line and then the next bit
is one in both cases so we're in the
right half of this sub number line we
cut our space in half and then we do it
again and now we see there a different
bit 5 has a 07 has a 1 and that's the
bit that determines the order now we've
ordered five is before seven because we
saw that bit it's kind of trivial all
we've done is reconstructed inches
you're ordering but this idea of like
looking at the bits in order it's
creating a spatial structure on our on
our numbers and in fact that's exactly
what morn order and 2d is doing and more
than order in 3d by by analogy I'm just
going to go through 2d in the same way
and so the only difference between the
1d example is now we're going to
alternate coordinates as we go so we
start with the x coordinate and so I've
picked two coordinates this this is yeah
five four and four five and I've gone
down to three bit numbers so the first
one is ones and so it's on the right mo
side and I'm going to put them copy
those bits here and let's go to the next
one so we go to the y axis once again
there are ones here so it's this it's
the same but we're now looking
vertically and we pick the one side
switch back and go to the next bit zeros
so see now we're in this we've like
descended one level or inside this box
and we picked the zero side of that so
once again we're looking for that first
bit where there's a difference we
haven't run into it and switch hexes and
we're kind of at the zero side of that
and now the first place we see a
difference is in the x-coordinate in the
third bit and that is actually what
determined the ordering so because it
was a zero in 45 this one comes first
and then the 154 comes second one thing
we get out of this is these morn indices
and you'll notice the way I wrote them
out those are now just binary numbers
you compare them like normal integers
and you get this ordering naturally so
one way to do this is just to take your
coordinates and you leave the bits and
now you have an index that defines the
ordering and that's as kind of a nice
way to think about it but the other way
is we kind of the first bit but differed
in this this index or the first like the
bit the most significant bit across the
two coordinates kind of breaking the tie
towards like the earlier coordinates is
another way of thinking of how we came
up with this ordering and there's a very
close relationship between what we just
did in octrees and you kind of saw it in
the diagram because it's like word we
have the outer box and its kind of split
into four sub squares and basically we
keep going to sending a square so let's
do this again but from that perspective
so instead of grouping the bits as like
the coordinates one by one as we're
doing let's put them together so we have
the first bit of both coordinates that
gives us two bit numbers and the order
of that is 0 1 2 3 so I've chosen a
different axis than most people who make
more than ordered
so this is not actually a Zed but
basically one thing to note is you'll
see this is 0-star0 star so all of the
zero bits going here or like with it
starts with 0 0 so we'll see see that a
little later how that makes things nice
we go to the next bit so we pick any XY
for the first bit and then look through
how that bit works and basically each of
these quadrants is now ordered in the
same kind of configuration and then we
do it again and we're one level deeper
so in this case we have 16 sub sub
squares and each one is ordered in this
this way so from what we just did we can
actually see two correspondences that
are very useful and that is that you
pick any node in your awk tree or
quadtree and all of its leaf nodes are
contiguous in the representation so let
me kind of show how that how I mean that
so the leaves are these guys and like we
pick one of these nodes like we are
let's pick the node 0 1 so that's 0 star
star 1 star star so we go down a level
that's all of all of these ones and
basically we're going to go through
these these points these points it's
like these arrows never cross into
another node is basically one other way
of saying that it's like all of these
leaves happen inside of this so if you
have an octree and you're like well I've
got a node what is everything in there
go to sort of Morton sorted order and
they're all contiguous and the other
property is that if we visit our nodes
in depth first order that is actually
producing Morton order maybe a little
caveat with that that means we're
visiting the children in our octree in
this order so we're basically at this
level we're going 0 1 2 3 and then
recursively visiting the nodes in a
depth-first manner so that means we
visit all the children of zero and then
all the children of one but you can
imagine how that how that does it how
that work so here in this node I go down
a level and then we go down a level and
then we look at these first four we go
back up we follow the arrow we're at
zero one is it be so we're just going
through everything in morn order so both
of these two properties let you design
how you deal with like leaf nodes that
are for a like child vauxhall or leaf
foxhole and group things in a way that's
always contiguous like basically a pair
of indices gets you all of the points
and correspondingly if you have things
in more in order getting to the octree
is easy because you know it's if you
just walk through the points you're
going to hit it in a way that's
equivalent to this depth first traversal
so let's apply this to a point cloud
it's pretty simple we need to define the
outermost box so we pick the rude nose
box I need to include all the particles
or all the points and then we need to
decide how deep the tree goes once you
pick that every
every point will correspond to a
particular Morton index and is a simple
mapping so you can sort all your points
and then you can build up your octree
and you're off to the races but what did
we have to do to do that well first for
the first one to pick the root node we
kind of need to know the bounding box of
the points right that kind of sucks is
like we need to go through all the
points and find that before we can start
really doing our work and also how do we
decide how deep it should be it's like
well that's kind of related to the
spatial properties it's like if you want
to be adaptive it's like there's more
points you kind of want to go deeper
there it's like but not here like how do
you how do you pick what that bottom of
the things should be and the big thing
is that's what the spatial data
structure was here to the begin with so
washed why do we have to know this
information before we're building our
actually getting to the spatial data
structure so what do we need or what
what could we do to alleviate that if we
made an octree that just covered all the
floating point numbers well that would
that would help right then there's no
question of what the root note is and we
can do that and then just throw away
you'll get a chain that goes to the
route that contains everything um that
turns out not to be too bad what about
knowing the spatial properties well we
can just have that octree continue all
the way down to the bottom of floating
point representation and from there we
can group things up to like make
aggregate chunks and do faster
processing um that's also not too bad
and the way to do this is with basically
extending more in order to work on
floating point numbers so I'm going to
give you two ways to think about this
first is with fixed point numbers and so
a fixed point number is like basically
an integer
where you then pick where the decimal
point is so the binary representation
you might pick okay 16 bits go to the
integer part and then 16 bits go to the
decimal part and it's maybe a little
tricky to imagine at first if you're not
used to this kind of thing but 32-bit
floats are actually all a subset of 276
bit fixed point numbers so if we apply
this integer Morton order operation 276
bit integers then we've got a more in
order and that just goes naturally to
the floating point no problem um that's
kind of like that doesn't help you
compute it you don't want to like
actually make 276 bit numbers for for
this so I'll take us at another from
another angle let's define real Mort in
order so we go the other way like all
real numbers can we order them in this
morning fashion and yes we can so any
real number you can represent it as a
basically an infinite sequence of bits
and you just take those you paint your
leave them and if you think about how
you might compare two floating point
numbers made of an infinite sequence of
bits well it's going to be that you find
the first bit that's different and that
determines the ordering and that's
actually where like that works just fine
in this you interleave the bits and you
get the right properties it works now
it's maybe a little tricky but like it
works out actually quite nicely in
floating point representation as well so
we had this correspondence with an
octree before the integer coordinates
integer octree so what does the octree
for this real Morton order look like
it's basically you get a root node
that's infinite that's all covering all
of real space then it has like eight
infinite children that are like the
eight octants of your real space and
eight octants in 3d in the 3d case
actually then each of those octants has
an infinite octree below it that is made
of finite nodes and each of those nodes
corresponds to a voxel that's like a
power of two width it's sizes it's
corners are at like coordinates
divisible by that power of two so it's
like theoretically it works out pretty
pretty simply there's like some special
cases at the top of these two levels of
infinite nodes but it's it's pretty
straight forward otherwise and going to
the floating point octree is just
truncating that to the representable
numbers and floating point and the
floating point morn orders is truncating
that real more in order to floating
point numbers as well so I'll show you
some code that does this it's basically
one of the ways i explained to do the
comparison is like finding the first bit
that's different on each of the x and y
coordinates and or XYZ coordinates and
then if there's a tie for the earliest
bit like taking the one that's the
earliest coordinate so first we have a
function that will compute well what's
the bit that's different and so just
using couple of standard library
functions to basically pull apart the
floating point number grab its exponent
use some knowledge of the double
precision exponent of 53 or the size of
the mantissa in that case and we can say
like where is the bit
differs then we can use that to build up
the full board in comparison it's
basically go through the coordinates and
in this case I've written this code so
it's arbitrarily dimensional D is the
number of dimensions in this case and we
loop through the dimensions we find the
bit that's different if we're yeah if
the bid is sooner for this coordinate
then we override it otherwise if it's a
tie we leave it or if it's worse believe
it and then we compare those numbers for
that dimension in practice what we've
done is written some simdi code with
sse2 to sort of try to tweak the
performance of this and it works out
pretty well you get pretty good
performance on this primitive operation
so that doesn't quite get us to where we
need because now we have a naught tree
where each point in the point cloud is a
leaf node which is kind of crazy we want
leaf nodes that are a little bit chunky
they've got a little bit of a de to them
so that we can like do vectorized
operations and once on it so we want to
build up the octree and merge these
nodes as we as we go so the rough
algorithm is to basically maintain a
stack of all the node references that
we've seen so far and when we hit a
point that's in a new node we basically
go through where the parent voxels would
be until we hit one that's a common
parent that was already seen and then go
back down and build the octree so it's
pretty straightforward to just walk
through the points in floating point
wharton order and build the octree and
it actually works out really nice
because you're allocating the nodes in
the order of a depth
search so it's over it's cash friendly
in many ways it's it works out quite
well so the final algorithm is you have
your input points coming from somewhere
and you stream them directly into the
sorting algorithm so if it's out of core
it's like you'll be straining them into
something that makes sorted chunks and
then does an external merge on that if
it's all in memory it's like well you
fill it you sort it you don't need to do
one pass and then a second pass it's
just like goes straight into that that
phase of the algorithm then you want to
go through the sordid points and chunk
them up if you're like picky about the
implementation details well you probably
want that final sorting result of your
out of core algorithm to end up going
directly to the chunking algorithm not
like write it out sorted and then go
through it again so I mean you don't
have to be wasteful here and then if
you're saving when you're saving it to
disk you also say what Fox will it came
with and that basically gives you a
spatial format on disk that you can
easily load into an octree and like load
anywhere in space pretty quickly so
there's one more detail that we do that
is important is that we also then go and
decimate the points based on some kind
of level of detail criteria so
I'm not going to go into that in depth
but let's talk a little bit about what
our result is so this is a screenshot of
Sequoia and basically we've got a
viewport so you can see like information
about the points you've loaded and like
yeah some niceties for just dealing with
with point clouds and what we've been
doing the tests out stuff like this
algorithm is like how do we push
scalability one way to scale is towards
large point clouds we pushed it out to
about 19 billion or so points i mean at
at that level i mean we can keep pushing
it but it's a pretty good benchmark of
of like how well do we work and then the
other way is pushing it towards small
hardware so we run demos on surface
tablets and so if you do dealing with
like 150 million points on a surface
tablet to like go around and stuff
that's that's pretty cool I mean it's a
small device but it can still push like
it's still handle these large point
clouds and let you do stuff in a kind of
compact form this is of course only a
small part of how you build an a robust
point cloud system so we've also got a
lot of asynchronous processing so like
you can keep interacting while stuff
goes on caching multithreading lots of
things going to it a direction we're
working more and more towards is
increasing out of core processing and
distributed getting distributed
computing into it and this is kind of a
common theme that I've seen here like a
s frame and sra there it's about out of
core algorithms on data frames
task because a library out of core
processing it's it's very like like
there's both several different angles
that it's happening within the Python
data community so in point cloud
software that sort of splitting has to
be some kind of spatial criteria
generally and so we're working on our
different algorithms to sort of like
make them work nicely in that so what a
the screenshot here is of deadline which
is our render farm management system and
we're basically integrating with that to
improve its ability to do distributed
computing style things and mix it up
with our Sequoia processing so I'm going
to finish it up talking a little just a
little bit about how how does this
connect to open source so the dying
library is a project I've started that
is like numpy but it's kind of a pure
C++ library lets you define dynamic
typed arrays and it has some goals of
connecting that kind of data between
languages like software languages and
between in this case between like
commercial and open source software
Marshall other software various
open-source software I think the kind of
data that you have in a point cloud
system should be easily accessible to
other systems and the yeah development
of diet is sort of aiming towards being
able to provide that kind of
infrastructure so yeah that's everything
I I prepared so thanks for coming and
invite any any questions people might
device
um well there's a lot of brands of lidar
scanners and that's that's the typical
thing like if you're not familiar with
what what its leg is basically so
there's ones that you put on a tripod
and it's got a spinning spinning mirror
and a laser that bounces off of it and
it measures the time of flight back and
forth and then as usually has a camera
that also takes images that it can
reproach am and the laser laser point so
you can also mount these devices on
planes or helicopters or drones and like
fly them around and get aerial scans no
that's a pretty like so that one see I
think that was about 800 square
kilometers of like the central
California coast that particular data
set like the more typical sizes I've
been seeing is like hundreds of millions
for like scanning a work site or
something I mean it really depends on
how how much surface area are covering
and how like much precision you get and
how how many samples you try to get to
cover over the area
um I do have let's see
so yeah so i haven't prepared anything
like for this but maybe load up load up
a point cloud and show a little bit of
what it what it looks like so here's the
are actually wait I've got a switch to
this duplicate alright so yeah here's
our application i'll create a point
loader and maybe okay i did one before
ok hello
so this is like a point cloud from so
it's like one piece from an aerial scan
that's just seven million points so the
full in that directory there were about
two thousand individual files and we can
merge them all together in the spatial
format I didn't think ahead to do that I
put it on my laptop it's like it's on
our servers back at back at home if I
load see
so like this is a so I've got this in
manual mode but and yeah I'm on battery
on my laptop right now so it's like in
power saving modes but kind of gives you
an idea of its this is a 26 million
point file and like it's fairly fairly
interactive to manipulate in no no that
it's well the market sector is often
called AEC are architects engineers
construction so like sites like this
where you want to do measurements on
like where things actually are as
opposed to where the blueprints said or
like I've heard during construction
nowadays it's like it might be cheaper
to just do lidar scans repeatedly and
see the progress of construction that
way as opposed to trying to like combine
the paperwork from everything getting
done
is there some sort of plan we're talking
about give you skin samples and say a
knife or something some sort of the
device we can buy or lake yeah well the
Kinect is exactly I mean any any kind of
depth camera technology is basically
giving you this so you like combining
like Kinect scanning with like tracking
either sort of like some kind of SLAM
mapping to figure it out or like sensors
on it on the device you can do that like
people yeah use connects to create point
clouds like this it's it's definitely
possible to do that as a hobbyist yeah
the the morn order and octree isn't the
thing that lets you do that but you kind
of add another level of detail layer
where you decimate the points so we
decimate the points and keep it on the
same octree so we can like select based
on the camera which level of detail
should each voxel be and then load just
those ones from disk because we have our
spatial index alright well thank you
very much for coming and enjoy the rest
of the PI data